يمكن انا متفائل زياده عن اللزوم لان
حقيقه يرجى الانتباه اغلب الدول بما فيها
امريكا
عندهم مشاكل في الامن عندهم مشاكل في
الصحه عندهم مشاكل في الموظفين عندهم
مشاكل سياسيه يعني انا عندي اهلي موجودين
في امريكا في الزياره ما احد ما في عندنا
حد بالكوفي في اللوبي الا بعد الساعه 11
يقول لك شرطه بستاف امنيا لكل واحد لازم
ينتبه ما يقدر يطلع من الفندق اللي يكون
لابس لباس معتدل وهذا نفس الشيء في اوروبا
كذلك صاير ولكن كذلك في نظري
بكل المصاري في الدول
هذه صرفت فلوس في الحروب الان تصرف فلوس
لا بد من يوم من الايام الارتفاع الضرائب
ولكن من هو الحزب القادر انه هو منتخب من
اجل رفع الضرائب انا اعتقد ايام من
القادمه في المنطقه العربيه هي ايام ذهبيه
لان احنا ما شاء الله بلدان كلها همم يعني
عندها التزام وعندها انضباط مالي وخصوصا
طبعا
ما شاء الله قادتنا الجدد وعلى راسم سمو
الامير محمد بن سلمان في انضباط في
الاداره في انضباط في الصرف في انضباط في
في الشفافيه في العمل فنعتقد
السنوات القادمه والله اعلم هي سنوات
الذهبيه بالنسبه للمنطقه ان شاء الله